mittwoch 5 august hat es angefangen hier
auf dem balkon zu brennen meine frau und
ich lagen im bett mit dem kleinen die
frau ist wach geworden hat eingesehen
dass er auf dem balkon angefangen zu
brennen oder beziehungsweise hat
gebrannt
meine frau kam dann schreiend ins
schlafzimmer sein hat mir berichtet also
berichtete hat mich schreibend geweckt
der balkon brennt der wald brennt dachte
dass mal was jetzt los ich träume noch
und das war egal also für mich war das
absolut keine realität in dem moment ein
kurs richtung balkon gelaufen habe
gesehen wie es lichterloh gebrannt hat
die hitze war schon zu spüren
habe meinen sohn aus dem web geschnappt
bei einer frau gegeben habe bei darunter
geschickt habe noch versucht irgendwas
zu retten konnte ich eigentlich nichts
mehr so schnell aber der rauch und ruß
das war alles so dicht und heiß muss
sich selbst runter das war so eine
unwirkliche situation also es war also
von null auf hundert im nächsten moment
dachte nur 'was wie schnell wird das
vorher jetzt sein
zum glück ist meine frau vorher
wachgeworden jalloud versicherungs
gutachten hätte ich im umgang mit mit
mit glimmenden tabak resten falsch
gehandelt obwohl ich nichtraucher bin
aktuell wohnen wir in einer mietwohnung
die wir über bekannte bekommen haben
für meine frau ist es jetzt auch viel
stress weil sie ist schwanger und da
haben wir so also ich habe persönlich
die angst dass ich über den stress
irgendwas auf kind überträgt den sauer
auf die versicherung dass nämlich
wirklich so alleine lassen
das versucht nun die schuhe zu schieben
ich erwarte von der versicherung dass
sie endlich einlenkt unser geld kriegen
auf das uns zusteht und das für zurück
können ja der gutachter vermutete dass
das feuer durch tabak reste entstanden
ist obwohl unser zuschauer herr lee sagt
ich brauche wirklich nur noch ganz
selten wirklich denkt vielleicht mal auf
einer party wenn ich wirklich betrunken
bin kann man der versicherung da
irgendwie beine machen arndt kempgens
das kann man schon wir haben ja erst mal
der versicherungsfall ist ja der brand
selber das ist der versicherungsfall und
wenn
jetzt hier der versicherungsfall
feststeht dann versucht der versicherer
in vielen fällen sich natürlich auf der
anderen seite wieder sozusagen ein
bisschen daraus zu lavieren das erleben
wir in der praxis natürlich regelmäßig
zumindest ich anwaltlich weil ja niemand
zu mir kommt alles läuft sondern wir
haben ja nur mit problemen zu tun und
der versicherer beruft sich hier
offenbar auf fahrlässigkeit auf grobe
fahrlässigkeit das ist nämlich ein
einwand der die leistungspflicht
deutlich reduzieren kann sogar völlig
ausschließen kann
und da ist der versicherer über in der
darlegungs und beweislast und der muss
sich sozusagen auf diesen einwand
berufen und hier kann man natürlich die
versicherung unter druck setzen man
sollte fristen setzen wenn man also
sagen wir mal alle unterlagen dorthin
geschickt hat alle anfragen beantwortet
hat zahlungsfrist setzen von zwei wochen
und wenn dann eben nicht bezahlt wird
besteht auch die möglichkeit klage
einzureichen
und dann muss der versicherer nämlich
diesen haftungs einwand nämlich grobe
fahrlässigkeit das muss der versicherer
im prozess fall beweisen was heißt denn
genau grobe fahrlässigkeit ist das
tatsächlich ich habe meine kippe
irgendwohin geschnippt und dann fängt es
an zu brennen
definieren sie das nochmal naja wir
müssen so ein bisschen unterscheiden
zwischen fahrlässigkeit das ist wenn man
sagt man was hast du denn da verrücktes
gemacht und grobe fahrlässigkeit und ab
da wird das erstversicherung schädlich
und das ist dass man wirklich sagt man
was bist du für ein idiot das ist
sozusagen grobe fahrlässigkeit
der bundesgerichtshof formuliert das
natürlich etwas vornehmer wer die im
verkehr erforderliche sorgfalt außer
acht lässt das ist verlässlichkeit und
das in einem besonders weibliche maße
das ist grobe fahrlässigkeit und so kann
man etwa den unterschied sehen wenn man
sich sozusagen also eine kopf was das du
sagst herr x wie kann man nur so ein
trottel sein dann kann das grobe
fahrlässigkeit sein und dann kann die
versicherung versuchen die
versicherungsleistung leistung zu
verkürzen
unser zuschauer hat bild kämpft
eingeschaltet wir konnten zumindest ein
teilerfolg erringen
zumindest die hausratversicherung hat
jetzt einen vorschuss von 30.000 euro
überwiesen
auch sonst hätte das verfahren
wahrscheinlich länger gedauert aber dann
hat die familie zumindest 30.000 euro
und kann wirklich die allerschlimmste
not noch lindern